blow your nose I never drank in college
you shouldn't either
how are you great you have some schmutz
on your face let me get it can you help
me put songs on my iPhone it was last
time you showered I remember when you
were that small I have so many coupons
have you gained a little weight now make
sure you send a thank-you note that was
very nice it's not you I don't trust it
to them his music is awful I can't hear
myself fake you need some money here
alright guys everyone smile what about
that boy from church Julie you're not
smiling don't make me turn this car
around no your body's gonna be changing
soon I'm going to count to three one
what does it mean when you get an
eggplant chew let's go stop in the
Barnes and Noble's I like that ariana
grande songs finish your food you
ordered that who even watches this
garbage
this is called Oh send this back Jenna
are you in there
Jenna I'll talk to his mom for you why
do you need to be on birth control you
don't have acne Jenna why can't you be
more like your brother you're not
leaving the house like that why don't
you wear there's a nice slacks we bought
are you using protection
be careful elbows off the table no
texting at dinner Oh your grandmother
now come give me a kiss don't leave the
house without a sweater you'll catch a
cold and you'll die why did you send me
a poop text message today you know I
don't find that funny that's an awfully
long shower